good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on Sky News
this Monday morning mainland China the
Senate's biggest protest since the
chairman Square massacre in 1989.
seething anger and resentment at the
government's zero covered policy is
Spilled Out onto the streets in cities
right across the country one of the
triggers was images of crowds at the
World Cup not wearing masks which show
how the rest of the world has moved on
from Lockdown and restrictions also this
morning reports back here that the Army
could be drafted in to fill Frontline
roles in hospitals to help support a
strike hit NHS speaking to the business
secretary Grant chaps and the unions
later this hour it is Monday the 28th of
November
Sky news witnesses more arrests this
morning as the Chinese Communist Party
attempt to contain the biggest challenge
to its Authority in more than a
generation
the arrests happened here in Shanghai
where people have been openly critical
of the government many have told us they
want their freedoms back
preparing to send in the army military
personnel could drive ambulances and
fill Frontline roles in hospitals during
strikes
we're set to find out this week if
thousands of paramedics will go on
strike joining cleaners Porters and
pharmacy technicians
good morning from Qatar where we'll have
the very latest as England and Wales are
in final preparations before their
crucial match tomorrow
out of the Jungle and heading home
former Health secretary Matt Hancock
faces questions about his political
future after he finishes third on I'm a
celebrity
hi folks not too bad unfortunately you
guys are all gonna have to walk to the
venue it's fall is it what is it I don't
know
busted on their way to the ball how
police caught 20 people in Black Tie in
the back of a horse box
and a Jurassic attraction a replica of
what could have been the largest animal
ever to walk the earth is to go on
display at the Natural History Museum
[Music]
morning everyone protesters in Shanghai
have chanted down with the Chinese
Communist party and free the people
anger and resentment over the country's
zero covered policy has provoked the
biggest protest since the 1980s in
cities right across China this morning
there are more people on the streets
than there have been more arrests
witnessed by our own team let's get more
should we Helena is standing by for us
in Shanghai what's going on Helena good
morning
foreign
good morning Kate well if the atmosphere
in the city last night was emotional and
angry the atmosphere in the city this
morning is very very tense indeed we're
actually broadcasting to you from quite
a few roads away actually from where the
main site of the protests were last
night and the night before we were over
there this morning and frankly it's just
not safe for us to broadcast live from
there right now the second we pulled the
camera up police immediately on us
immediately following us um there have
been a lot of arrests over the last
couple of days we actually witnessed one
person being dragged Away by police from
that very sort of high tension hot spot
if you like we weren't really sure what
it is he had done perhaps just linger a
little too long and there have been
multiple foreign journalists arrested as
well in the last couple of days so a
very very tense atmosphere but worth
saying there were young people going to
that crossroads where people have been
gathering over the last couple of days
they weren't making it obvious that they
were there to protest but I think it was
pretty clear to everyone that that is
why they had gone there but what has
been seen across China over the last
couple of days is really quite
extraordinary incredibly rare and these
are the scenes we witnessed last night
in Shanghai
as night fell in Shanghai they gathered
in their hundreds ordinary angry people
facing up to the authorities
stood largely in silence words can be
dangerous here but there was a power in
them being withheld their presence alone
spoke volumes the roads are completely
blocked here by police but that hasn't
stopped hundreds of other people
Gathering here holding up signs white
pieces of paper that's becoming a real
symbol of the process here it's hard to
express just how incredibly unusual
these scenes are in China
his rage is a fire on the other side of
this vast country covered rules
allegedly trapped those inside ten lost
their lives
the final straw it seems for many in a
zero covered pressure cooker
among the crowd we met this group of
young friends brimming with passion and
Incredibly Brave
[Music]
[Applause]
with me
[Applause]
people spontaneously applauded her for
speaking and chanted freed the people
[Applause]
there's a sense that people are really
angry is that is that right
um
really upset it's not really like we're
angry because there's other countries
our interview was suddenly cut short by
this
the police charging arresting everyone
who could run
and back but they did not disperse
a thing that makes protests like what we
saw last night as extraordinary as they
are is not just the openness with which
people are calling for things like the
downfall of the government that is
almost unheard of here but it is also
the fact that similar protests have been
springing up in multiple cities
simultaneously and that has not happened
for many decades in this country and I
cannot overstate enough just how
extremely risky it was for every single
person that went to that protest last
night they were taking enormous personal
risks to be there and the fact they were
out in such numbers with such bravery
really was extraordinary so all eyes on
what happens next whether there will be
repeats of protests both here in
Shanghai tonight and in other cities
it's not clear yet what does feel likely
in this city is that if there are more
Gatherings they will be clamped down on
much more swiftly and potentially much
more aggressively that's how it feels
right now but the Communist Party of
China faces a huge dilemma now what to
do whether to crack down heavily in
militarily whether to offer some
concessions whether to draw back some of
those covered rules that people are so
so weary over that poses risks for them
not least of a big covert outbreak the
thing they want to avoid but also
sending a message to people that
protests work something they would also
want to avoid so the next 24 48 hours or
so I think really pivotal pivotal for
this country that is already
experiencing a historic period okay for
now thanks so much indeed back home the
Army could be brought in to drive
ambulances and stand in for Frontline
Hospital roles under emergency plans to
deal with possible strikes this winter
let's get more with Sadia who's standing
by for us at Saint Thomas's hospital
just across the river here in central
London this morning so it's not yet been
confirmed but it is suggested that the
Army could get involved if necessary
good morning
foreign
k no it hasn't been confirmed and there
hasn't been a formal request made by the
department for health to the Minister of
Defense but it's all about contingency
plan so the Army is looking at
contingency plans and the government is
also looking at contingency plans and
one of those things is a protocol called
Maca which stands for military aid for
Civil Authorities and all of that is
aimed at making sure that the NHS
continues its service if strike action
is as bad as health leaders fear that it
could be now anyone who remembers the
last time the ambulance Strikers went on
ambulance drivers went on strike late
1989 to early 1990 May record seeing the
Army the Navy even the Royal Air Force
getting involved in trying to transport
patients while those drivers were on
strike and of course we've seen the Army
in more recent days during the pandemic
when they set up mobile testing units
for the for covert testing and delivered
PPE but it is one thing to have the Army
deploy during a pandemic and quite
something else to see soldiers on the
streets during normal times but it just
goes to show the sort of expectation of
the stresses that the NHS might come
under this winter and it's not just
ambulance drivers of course who are set
to go on strike last week the Royal
College of Nursing announced that its
members across England Wales and
Northern Ireland will go on strike on
December 15th and 20th we know that
hospital cleaners Porters pharmacy
technicians midwives Junior doctors all
of them considering strike action the
government is looking at ways that it
can try and convince these workers that
it is aware of the difficult conditions
that they work in some of the things
that they're considering are things like
free coffee free breakfast free parking
a very contentious issue so far all
these things look that they're looking
at to try and convince workers that they
do care but new pay packages aren't
being considered because the treasury is
adamant that that will just fuel
inflation okay thanks a lot
let's talk about it in more detail Kevin
Ryan head of public services at the
trade Union Congress is with us now hi
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us on the program
um
sit right with you that Armed Forces
Personnel could be
um working in our hospitals
well I think it doesn't sit right with
me that the hundreds of thousands of
health workers are feeling so pressed
and had done to in terms of payover and
let's face it last 10 12 years that the
only thing that they feel they can do to
try and get the government to listen to
them is to take uh industrial action I
mean new years and years of having
their peer settlements below inflations
with them so desperate that they're that
they're taking uh industrial action it's
you know it it's a real blight on this
government really that we've got to this
stage
90 pay rise were being told is what
nurses want effectively
um
can anybody justify 19 increase in their
salary um at the present time
well that reflects the fact that there
have been years of below inflation pay
Rises and in real terms nurses are about
5 000 pounds a year worse off than they
were in 2010 so the uh the the logic of
you if you like of that peer claim is
there for everyone see nurses health
workers right across ambulance drivers
and the whole list of workers that you
are reporters just uh uh just outlined
Are all uh that much worse off in real
terms that that kind of payer claim just
brings them back to the levels of pay
that in real terms that they were
experiencing in 2010 it doesn't seem
right to me that we praise our health
service so highly that we clap them
through the pandemic and yet in real
terms there's so much worse off that
they feel that the only cost of action
that they can take is to push back and
and demand a really significant pay rise
through industrial action yeah but I
mean the country's not got any money at
the moment has it
well the government would like you to
believe this is an economic choice but
it's a political choice if they were to
tax capital gains and inheritance tax at
the same rate of income tax and there'd
be enough money to pay every single
Health worker that that pay rise but
they're choosing to tax workers and not
to tax wealth so these are political
decisions that the government is making
there is uh you know resources available
they're just not choosing to to bring
them to the table
um the government would say in response
to that I suppose that it's a fine line
between
um taxing those that are more wealthy
and taxing them as wealth creators to
the extent that they decide to go and
take their finances elsewhere in this
global economy
it is a balance absolutely no one's
going to push back a mother but the fact
is shareholder dividends have been
rising three times faster than uh than
wages in the economy so there is and
there is a balance to be struck but the
balance at the moment seems to very much
favor uh wealth uh in the country and
very much uh damage uh and ham uh
working people we all we all rely on and
the balance has been so bad I say
workers are feeling so desperate that
they're taking the action that they're
taking
cook a TUC afford to pay its stuff an
extra 19 assume
well
it's not the same scenario our stuff
haven't had uh years and years of below
inflation uh pay Rises so we we have a
good relationship with our trade unions
and we uh you know we work out what we
can afford to play our stuff and we pay
them well uh public sector workers uh
literally uh rocking up at food banks
because they're being so squeezed for so
many years
yeah but I suppose my question is could
you afford to pay an extra 19 is that
what was being asked this year or do you
do are you is the business in such a
state that actually you can't do that at
the moment well what the TUC and all of
our trade unions have never said is that
you know employers shouldn't pay
unaffordable pay Rises where private
sector employers can afford to pay pay
risers they are doing in many cases and
so they should and the difference
between uh if you like the private
sector and organization like the TUC and
public sector is it's the government's
choices that are impacting on those
wages and the government are choosing
they are choosing uh to uh uh not tax
Capital wealth and they are choosing to
tax working people and keep working
people you know hard pressed that's a
political Choice it's different to uh to
the one that uh private sector
organizations having to make government
minestrone sky yesterday said that 19 is
unaffordable from what you're saying you
say that's not the case and the NHS can
afford to pay nurses 19 more this year
I'm saying that the government are
making political choices uh in order to
uh you know uh favor the the wealth in
this country and and uh and put pressure
on working people if the government were
to introduce capital gains and
inheritance tax at the same rate as
income tax they'll be a lot of hard to
pay nurses an inflation busting parents
absolutely they would
do you think that it's affordable for
the NHS this year to pay 19 given Where
We Are
well I'm not in the negotiations with
the NHS Empire you're here representing
the TUC today and that in turn
represents the unions and what I'm
saying to you is that if the government
had a fairer tax system they would the
NHS would absolutely be able to afford
to pay for workers yeah but that I mean
we've just seen the Autumn budget we're
not going to get another Autumn
statement or we're not probably going to
get anything until at least the spring
so given where we are it does you're
saying that that the NHS can still
afford to pay 19 to nurses as we speak
and if they don't get it they're going
to go on strike it seems like the
British public is caught between a rock
and a hard place
well the British public are absolutely
being caught between a rock and a hard
place the people who can move that rock
or move that hard place either
government by making different choices
on taxation
uh this um strike ballot with ambulance
workers England and Wales and that is
we're expecting that later on in the
week the results of that how do you
expect that to go
well from what I hear the the anger
that's right across the Health Service
right across education and many public
services and parts of the private sector
economy is that people feel that they've
got no choice but to uh stand up
together to try and push back against
the pay deals that they've got so I
would expect those uh balance to be in
favor of industrial action and it's a a
really you know very sad situation that
workers feel so bad that they have to
take that action and do you think that
military personnel can do as good a job
as the ambulance man and women
uh well I I doubt it and to be frank I
mean you know these these professionals
have been working uh very hard in the
sector and very well trained for such a
long time it's you know uh there is life
on limb cover as well Arrangements in
place across the Health Service of
course uh but no no one would expect uh
the Army to do the same quality of job
as as professional paramedics and
ambulance staff so you have to accept
that at that patients lives will be put
at risk
well as I said our unions have got life
and limb cover Arrangements in place
across the Health Service nobody wants
to do this in order to damage uh patient
care you know that all of the people
I've ever come across in the head in the
NHS are incredible committed
professionals and they just feel so
desperate that they they have to take
this action but there is life and Loom
cover in place and uh people will
obviously be very conscious of the uh
impact and risk of the action that
they're taking okay it's good to talk to
you thanks for taking the time to join
us this morning thank you
so uh waiting to hear what's going to
happen as far as the ambulance service
is concerned uh also the nurses going on
strike the postman on strike the rail
workers are on strike nine o'clock on
Thursday morning joined by union leaders
to answer your questions as the country
faces a wave of strikes not seen in a
generation you can tweet me at Cape
early with your questions those
questions can be in written form if
you'd prefer you can send us a short
video and also we'll have an email
address that you can send it to as well
so that's Thursday at nine o'clock ask
the union leaders do you have a question
for the unions do you support their
action or do you feel that it will
impair your ability to go about your
everyday work do let us know your
thoughts um tweet me directly at K
Burley use the hashtag cabley or you can
email us and I'll send you I'll let you
have that email address in the fullness
of time
in a few moments joined uh by the
business secretary that's Grant chaps of
course also speaking to the former
brexit secretary David Davis as he calls
on the PM to enact emergency legislation
to help reduce the number of migrants
crossing the channel in small boats
and Labor's Shadow business secretary
that's Jonathan Reynolds will be with me
soon after eight o'clock
[Music]
lots to talk to Grant Sharps about this
morning hello to Mr chaps thanks for
joining us on the program
um let's let's start with the Union
should we just finishing
um there how are you feeling about the
possibility that the military is going
to be brought in to fill the Gap should
ambulance workers go on strike
yeah I saw that story I don't think
that's actually
um correct other than to say that the
government always looks at contingency
and plans but there aren't any immediate
plans to do that and actually the NHS
has got some pretty well versed uh
planning in place for all manner of
disruption of course ideally uh I I'd
love to see the those strikes perverted
um I don't think anyone wants to see
strikes in our NHS it harms everybody as
to no one's advantage
okay our nurse is worth a 19 pay rise
well we followed it's worth saying we
followed the NHS pay review body when it
comes to uh nurses which I think is a 1
400 pounds uh pay rise this year it
comes on top of I think three percent
last year when inflation was lower and
there were a lot of freezes
um elsewhere uh but you know I I'll
leave it to the to the experts on this
um and I think the main message to
everybody is and we don't want to see
strikes in our in our NHS you know we
will rely on it and um you know we want
to see it functioning normally the chap
who's now doing your former job Mark
Harper the transport secretary is saying
we can't afford
um a 10 pay rise an inflation busting
pay rise for anybody would you agree
with that
yeah I mean we've seen how this works
before
um I mean you have to go back several
decades but High inflation if you then
feed the high inflation with High
um settlements you end up in a spiral
where it never ends and that's what
happened in the 1970s uh we're very
determined not to be in that situation
now it won't benefit anybody
um and you know we all know the reason
for this we all understand that Putin
invaded Ukraine pushed up Energy prices
pushed up inflation uh we mustn't in but
mustn't chase that inflation otherwise
we won't get it out the system which in
a year's time we will have seen it
Fallen uh to half the current level
according to the independent officer
budget responsibility we want to see
that happen because inflation's really
the evil that we all need to defeat but
for the benefit of the whole society
yeah although you know the unions
disagree with you and they are starting
to square up to this government
um
certainly you weren't particularly
engaged with the transport unions when
you were a transport secretary um Jake
Berry the former Tory party chair
yesterday saying that was a big mistake
by you and your successor is now having
conversations with Mick Lynch and the
like
in hindsight do you think that you
should have engaged with the Union
sooner and we wouldn't have been in this
position
of course unions were sort of constantly
saying uh we we need to speak
um although the actual discussion needs
to be between the employer and the
unions themselves and as has rather
being demonstrated in fact the last two
transport secretaries I was actually
transport secretary three ago uh have
both spoken to the unions it doesn't
appear to stop them from announcing a
whole new set of strikes
um so it rather proves the point that
we've all been making uh myself and the
current uh transport secretary included
which is the only way to resolve these
strikes is for the unions and the
management
um the the rail operators the network
rail to discuss these things uh and
rather it brings a lie to the idea that
if only we sat down and spoke this would
all be over as the unions have been
claiming that simply is not true because
they are still striking yeah on the
contrary if you had sat down and talked
to them perhaps you wouldn't be in this
position
well why would that be the case um we're
still in that position with the last
couple why is your why is the trans
present transport secretary saying that
he will sit down and talk to them now
and you you just didn't want to
entertain them they said
because the only resolution to this is
between
um the management and uh the so he
shouldn't be chatting to them
but I mean it's not that you shouldn't
and actually I had spoken to Mick Lynch
in the past was the boss of the rmt is
simply that it doesn't seem to resolve
it one way or the other and I can prove
that point because the last couple of uh
transport secretaries have spoken to
them uh I uh I I I I I had a situation
where I allowed the unions and the
management who are the only people who
can resolve this to speak directly
actually transpires it doesn't matter
which way you go around this at the
union seem absolutely intent on causing
the maximum disruption to hard-working
people in this country it's time for
them to stop
um grandstanding and you know get this
thing um settled fortunately it actually
when it comes to rail there are lots of
modernizations that could be carried out
lots of them which could help to pay the
um their their uh their increase but
they don't want to modernize they want
to keep stuck in the 1970s and before
rather than modernize the railway and
that's a great shame because it's
costing all passengers a lot because of
that in transitions
talk to me about what's going on in
China you've obviously seen the images
overnight huge
stability their biggest protest since
Shannon square is what we're saying here
on Sky news this morning what does that
instability mean for us as a nation
well we're watching very carefully
indeed to see what's happening there
it's a reminder I think many of us will
have forgotten because we we haven't
been in lockdown for well over over a
year now I guess but it's actually still
going on there and it's a reminder that
the way we got out of the situation was
by having uh Mass vaccinations
pioneered here in the UK with the Oxford
AstraZeneca vaccine with the UK being
the first to vaccinate and therefore the
first major economy to come out of
lockdown they didn't follow that
approach in China and said they've gone
for a zero covid
um still back in the days where we'll
remember it when we're in lockdown here
and people are clearly becoming
impatient
um I I uh you know watching with with um
concern because I think it's very
important for the the question of
stability
um that for example vaccinations is is
the way forward to enable societies to
unlock
yeah but how concerned are we about that
instability I mean I know that the boss
is going to be speaking at the Guild
Hall tonight and he's going to be
talking about robust pragmatism and
that's what we need to do to stand up to
the likes of China and Russia I wonder
how that robust uh pragmatism actually
works though when we're seeing
protesters and accredited journalists um
being arrested and beaten
well there can be absolutely no excuse
whatsoever for journalists who are
simply covering uh the process going on
for being beaten by the police I know
that's a considerable concern but with
regard to The Wider issue uh you know
can you imagine have we have been locked
down for another year had we not acted
so quickly and it managed to mass
vaccinate people in this country
um I when I see those pictures it sort
of takes you back to you know the worst
days a couple of years ago of of
lockdown and people are clearly getting
pretty Fed Up about it but in terms of
our attitudes towards uh China
um it will be that robust pragmatism it
will always be saying China is a reality
um but we always need to you know remind
ourselves that they do not run the same
system of democracy that we're fortunate
to live under
tell me about your energy saving
campaign that you're going to launch
today is this the same one that Liz
trust said that we weren't going to do
well all I know is about the the
campaign I am launching which is a
billion pounds
um to both help people improve money
though is it
well that's billions on top of 6.6
billion that's been spent before so this
money is for people who've not been able
to benefit from the previous schemes and
we'll help hundreds of thousands of
homes but in addition I'm also
announcing that we're going to be
helping to just to inform people better
about how they can save energy one of
the tips by the way is something I've
actually been able to use at home it's
called The Boiler flow rate and it's
actually on your boiler where you can
turn the temperature down uh which is
often set to high at 75 degrees for
example to 60 degrees this is not your
thermostat this is in the boiler itself
and it can potentially save you a lot of
money on your mg costs each year so it's
actually actually simple tips like that
which we'll be announcing
um and there's an 18 million pound
campaign to to back that as well so lots
of practical help physically improving
people's homes and also tips to make
sure that people are able to save
themselves money by being more efficient
in the homes
onshore wind where are you on that at
the moment
I already have plenty of a lot of
onshore wind in this country we have the
world's most offshore wind of any
country in the world
um and uh you know I think offshore has
the potential to produce really I'm sure
we already have quite a lot of onshore
wind and we have any more
there will be more over time but
particularly where communities are in
favor of it that is I think the key test
for onshore wind giving some benefit to
a community's locally and that's always
been a principle for us for quite some
time now
looks as though um Simon Clark former
leveling up secretary Michael Gove who
is now the leveling up secretary uh but
both backing forcing the government's
hand on onshore wind and um Simon Clark
saying they're five MPS away from
forcing the government to do what they
want I don't recognize it in those terms
at all but Simon Clark
um it has put in an amendment uh which I
haven't studied all the ramifications of
yet but actually essentially saying
exactly what I said to you which is that
local people ought to have
um a very very keen say in this which is
indeed government policy there are
always different ways to skin a cat as
it were
um but we'll have a close look at what's
being proposed but uh sounds like it
sounds like the government might be
backing down on this one no exactly what
we've said all along that Rishi said the
other week where onshore happens it
needs to happen with local
um against it he says he said he was
against any further on Shore when he
said that earlier during the summer I
think you're being far too black and
white about this I've always said
yeah I absolutely pressed him on it and
he said he was against it he said I've
spoken the day before and he said he was
against on Shawan so so I've always said
and indeed he has always said where
onshore wind happens it needs to happen
with local consent uh what is being
proposed uh is something which would
guarantee that local incentives to say I
haven't studied all the ramifications uh
of that in terms of the planning changes
uh but to present it as some sort of
massive golfers completely untrue uh you
know we need and I'll be talking about
this more later in the week I've just
talked spoken to you about measures to
reduce energy use we also need to make
sure that we reduce more energy okay
I wonder if I could ask you two very
quickly questions I know you've got to
flee at the moment you were home
secretary you were home secretary for
six days I think I'm right in saying
um I'm hearing that David Davis is
writing to the prime minister to say
that anyone from safe countries like
Albania should summarily summarily have
their applications rejected do you agree
um so what I'd say is I I you know I I
have looked at this issue in some detail
because of being briefly Home Secretary
where countries are not uh where
people's lives are more at rest and
clearly and there isn't a case for
Asylum and then clearly that should be
dealt with quickly and efficiently and
that's what I'd say on that issue
um I'm so sorry but I actually have uh
one of your rival broadcasters calling
okay and I need to take that cool I
think we're over time
okay we do have 12 minutes with you
don't mean we've done 12 minutes and
four seconds so let me just ask you in
another 10 seconds Matt Hancock should
he be should he be able to be back with
the Tory whip now
um look I I don't think you should have
gone to the Jungle in the first place
and you know it's often said politics is
or show business for ugly people uh he
should be back here with with us ugly
people in Parliament doing the job for
his constituents and that's that's what
I think he should have done always fun
you're rather dushing actually uh Mr
chaps so it's lovely to talk to you as
always thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you thank you
uh top stories for you this morning and
there have been clashes and arrests in
Shanghai during unprecedented protests
across China against the country's covid
restrictions hearing there from Mr chaps
that he's very much as a member of the
government keeping an eye on that
uh the business secretary saying that
the only way to resolve Stripes is for
the unions to talk directly to
management but described inflation as an
evil that we all need to defeat
and out of the Jungle and heading home
former Health secretary Matt Hancock
facing questions about his political
future after he finishes third on I'm a
celebrity
Tamara is here thoughts this morning
tomorrow good morning morning Kay well
Richie see Knox facing various
rebellions from all sides within his own
party and I think we've got an
indication there from Grant chaps the
business secretary that he may be
preparing to give in on a rebellion
about onshore wind farms I remember very
well when he spoke to you during the
leadership campaign he said he didn't
think we need any more on onshore wind
farms that plans to relax the ban that
was brought in by David Cameron I
remember there was big outcry David
Cameron said we should restrict onshore
wind it's a plan to relax that were
wrong and he wasn't going to go ahead
with it that was the difference between
him and Liz truss now some conservatives
including Boris Johnson Liz trust
various other former cabinet ministers
now causing trouble on the back benches
are trying to bring onshore wind back
they say it's good for growth good for
the environment and good for homegrown
energy and I think Grant chaps there
saying I think we're all trying to
achieve the same thing make sure local
people are happy with it seem to open
the way to a compromise and with which
is soon already having to to pull some
legislation to do with building more
homes because a lot of Tories were angry
about it you can see that he's facing so
many difficult battles with his party is
he going to duck another one and
therefore how much of what machine told
us in the summer that he was going to do
is actually going to happen uh yeah
let's wait and see also um I mean
obviously we're being a little bit
flippant there about Matt Hancock but
it's a very real possibility that he
might not be able to stand as an MP a
Tory MP at the next election there's a
deadline on the 5th of December that's
right how could the morning go past I
was talking about Matt Hancock there
with a frog on his head
um so he came third at last night who
would have predicted that at the very
beginning had the whip of course
withdrawn
um he will need to get it back first of
all that would be the first battle now
Nadine dory's back uh 10 years ago so
when she went on the program she did get
the whip back when she returned so that
will be his first battle and suggestions
in the papers this morning that he's
looking to leave politics slapped down
by a spokesperson for Matt Hancock I can
tell you they say that he it's not true
that he is leaving politics and is
already contacting PR companies and they
say that a spokesperson told us he has
no intention of standing down or
stepping away and he hasn't had any
conversations with any PR companies and
as to confirmation about whether he
wants to stand the next election the
reason we've seen so many Tories of the
last few days saying they don't want to
stand is because the 5th of December is
when they have to decide and some of
them are having their seats affected by
changes to the boundary so the exact
seat they stood in may not exist in the
same form I think Matt Hancock's
constituency is one of those so we'll
watch this space on that but they say
that he has no intention of standing
down right now he's continuing until the
next election okay for now tomorrow
thank you let's have a look at the
mornings papers for you should we
starting with the financial times this
morning leading with the protests in
Shanghai as police struggle to disperse
large crowds in a grown wave of
discontent at China's Zero Tolerance
covid policies
an image of the protest is on the Times
front page but the paper leads with
plans to bring in Army Personnel to help
with walkouts as NHS strike action looms
the business secretary say he has no
knowledge of that Guardians saying that
brexit has worsened the nhs's shortages
of doctors leading to more than 4 000
European doctors choosing not to work in
the UK and finally the son claiming
there have been secret talks to get Matt
Hancock out of politics and into Showbiz
that's been rubbish by his team this
morning according to tomorrow
to the World Cup in Qatar now where
there have been more protests and
Germany has still not won a game
although you know to be fair they did
play quite well last night they were
saved from defeat against Spain by that
late goal but the Germans are currently
bottom of their group and will need to
win their last match to have a hope of
going through to The Knockout stages
earlier Morocco's done Belgium beating
them to nil the team ranked second in
the world may now need to beat Croatia
in a group F Showdown to progress
progress rather to the last 16 England
and Wales will be getting their final
training sessions in before the two
teams face off tomorrow night in one of
sports oldest rivalries uh Alistair
standing by for us in uh Doha it's the
game that everybody here in the UK is
waiting to see Alistair good morning
good morning yeah I'm sure it will
divide households in the UK and it'll be
watched by millions back at home it will
be watched by thousands of Welsh and
English fans who are here in Doha as
well it is a crucial match certainly for
the Welsh they have to beat England and
hope that the results in the other game
between the United States and Iran go
their way it is an uphill challenge for
Wales but no injury concerns that we
know of there'll be media conferences
later for both teams and they will hope
that with a good degree of support
behind them in the stadium and the fact
that you know it's a World Cup and we've
seen a number of upsets so far their
hope will be that they can do the same
against England as for England again
they're in training today there is a
little bit of pressure on Gareth Bale to
make some changes
um after that draw against the United
States when England were booed off the
field the England manager says that he's
not concerned group stages rarely go
smoothly but Harry Kane's got a little
bit of a knock on his ankles so there
might be a tempting Nation just to rest
him for the latter stages England's
qualifications understand he's not
absolutely guaranteed but things need to
go badly wrong for them for them not to
qualify and the other one is Phil foden
who a lot of people want to see come
into the team to add a bit of spark in
on in the side and so it might be that
with England sitting in a good position
at the top of the group
Gareth Southgate decides to bring in a
few new faces tomorrow okay for now
thank you looking at some of today's
other headlines for you now riots broke
out in several Belgian and Dutch cities
after Morocco beat Belgium in that match
we mentioned a moment ago police
arrested about a dozen people in
Brussels and held eight more in the
northern city of Antwerp two police
officers were injured when they were
pelted with fireworks and glass in the
Dutch Port City of Rotterdam
a landslide has killed at least 14
people who are attending a funeral in
Cameroon local officials say the service
was taking place on a football pitch in
the country's capital one of the wettest
cities in Africa
a vigil has been held for the six people
killed in a mass shooting and a Walmart
store in Virginia last week local
Congressman Robert Cortez Scott said
more needs to be done to solve America's
problems with gun crime
Chesapeake now joins a list of all too
many communities forced to Bear the
unbearable
now we now we know we can do better
there's no other country suffers gun
violence like America
and so we need to stand up and do
something about this problem
please have expressed their despair the
deaths of two more teenagers from knife
crime after another weekend of violence
in the capital 16 year olds Kern solanki
and Charlie Bartolo were found with stab
wins in southeast London yesterday
police say their deaths are linked and
in separate instance one man was shot in
South London and another died after a
street fight Emma hasmore
foreign
ly a steady stream of teenagers came to
mourn laying flowers at the scene of yet
another fatal stabbing in the capital
just a mile away from this estate in
thamesmead police stood guard at the
location of a second murder this time in
Abbey Wood the boys aged just 16 were
starved within a matter of minutes of
each other
homicide colleagues are investigating
and are treating the two murders as
linked
I can assure everybody affected by these
murders that skilled detectives will
work tires tirelessly to discover what
happened and provide answers to the
young victims and families
the 999 calls began coming in at around
10 past five on Saturday afternoon
paramedics attempted to save the boy's
lives but both were pronounced dead on
the street
they've been named by police as Kiani
solanki who was killed in thamesmead and
Charlie Bartolo
by mid-afternoon dozens of people had
gathered close to the scene in Abbey
Wood to remember yet another Young Life
lost they licked candles and placed them
next to the flowers and balloons were
released into the sky
for both communities it's been an
unbearable shock ambulance they try to
do their best and I think Unfortunately
they have to lose the boy
but then he's very sad and since then
all all the people in the community will
be mourning the boy the deaths come in
yet another weekend of violence London
figures from the metropolitan police
show violent crime with the blade was up
15 in October compared to the previous
month Anne-Marie cousins is the local
councilor for Abby wood
two 16 year old their babes two 16 year
olds think about that
police want to hear from anyone who saw
a dark SUV or 4x4 type vehicle with
silver roof bars at either location in
the days before the teenagers were
stabbed
as their families become the latest left
to mourn an unbearable loss in an
epidemic of violence
Emma birchley Sky News Southeast London
returning now to the protests that have
been taking place in cities across China
over the country's repeated covid
lockdowns and strict restrictions joined
Now by Victor go he's a businessman and
commentator who previously worked as an
English language interpreter for the
former Chinese leader dengia ping hello
chief thanks for joining us on the
program this morning
um what's your interpretation of what is
happening at the moment is it exhaustion
frustration both
first of all it is very rare for many
cities in China to witness
demonstrations almost at the same time
secondly the protests are very much
focused on the dynamic zero coffee
policy that China has practiced for the
past three years now I would say China
is in the transition period moving from
strict lockdown quarantine Etc to a more
flexible Paradigm going forward
originally our goal is to minimize
deaths and infections now I think we
need to pursue two goals to minimize
deaths and infections on the one hand
but also to make sure that people's
daily life and work process will be less
impacted or disrupted by the covet
policies now I think the protesters
demand that they get complete Freedom
they have legitimate reasons for the
calling for that on the other hand I
hope they will also realize that the
anti-covery policy is not against any
people or person it is really against
the virus and China has already achieved
unprecedented spectacular achievements
of minimizing deaths and infections
among the Chinese people during the past
three years and now we need to do
whatever we can to make sure that the
transition to the new roadmap will be
less costly going forward
so why are the Chinese people
demonstrating in such numbers and in a
way that we have not seen for a
generation
you're right I think many people are
inconvenienced and many people suffer
from the lockdowns or repeated lockdowns
Etc in that sense they have legitimate
reasons to demand the greater freedom
and greater more targeted policies uh to
prevent the infections or the deaths
among the people on the other hand I
think they do not fully understand why
the dynamic zero coffee policy has been
introduced and practiced for the past
three years at the same time because
ultimately the fact that we are all
alive and many of us are still healthy
is because of the dynamic zero coffee
policy itself because this has really
prevented massive around amounts of
infections among the Chinese people
minimizing the deaths among the Chinese
people I think the government need to
communicate to the people more
eloquently about what they have been
been doing for the past three years and
the reason why there are so many
disruptions and inconveniences and if
there are Corruptions involved in
testing for example making uh
illegitimate money from the testings Etc
they need to be brought to justice so I
think lots of things need to be done at
the same time but I personally would say
that the Chinese government and the
whole Chinese Nation have really made a
spectacular achievement in minimizing
deaths and infections for the past three
years it's time for us to move on to a
better Paradigm in achieving two goals
rather than only one goal it's good to
talk to you thank you for joining us on
the program this morning much
appreciated thank you
thank you very much for having me thank
you thank you more than 50 conservative
MPS have written to the Prime Minister
calling for a change to Modern slavery
laws to try to reduce the number of
migrants crossing the channel in small
boats join now by one of the signatories
the former brexit secretary David Davis
hi it's good to see you thanks for
joining us on the program what do you
want to see happen well the what's
happening at the moment got 12 000
albanians in one year from a safe
country you know it's a member of the
European convention on human rights as
we are and I want two things to happen
we want two things happen at one uh such
people to be told you can't claim Asylum
here immediately a summary decision on
that there's no argument for Asylum from
Albania here secondly those who use the
human trafficking laws we should say to
them look if you have been human
trafficked surely the right answer is to
put you back in your own home in your
own village back in Albania if you want
to process it beyond that then talk to
us after that but you're going home the
point is to turn the turnaround time for
for an Albanian landing on our Shores uh
from years to days or weeks and that's
the aim and we think it's possible if we
don't do it the homeless is never going
to be able to cope with the number of
applications it's gonna it's already 420
days to get a decision it'll get longer
and longer and eventually all those
decisions will allow people to say see
the home office doesn't agree with you
because of the 55 percent of Asylum
applications by adult albanians
um they've been they've been allowed to
stay no what's what's been happening to
it if you if you turn into two two
groups young men which is the vast
majority and uh women and children women
and children beginning about 85 approval
that's because the the home office
itself has not been interpreting the
Asylum laws correctly if so it's the
home office as well not the album It's a
mixture at the end of the day the blame
for this lands of the Albanian gangs who
bring them here not the albanians
themselves because they're all sorts of
failures of people it's the Albanian
gangs that bring them here but the
simple truth is that the home office is
interpreting Asylum laws to say if you
are in our in Albania not if a
government is oppressing you which is
what Asylum laws are like so you've been
talking about China somebody came from
China saying my government's going to
kill me we give them Asylum but uh if
they're facing gangsters criminal
activities inside their own country
that's a misinterpretation of this home
laws it was never designed for that well
interestingly the Albanian prime
minister saying that he's not having
albanians being scapegoated because of
failed policy here in the UK well I mean
I'm not escaping the individual
albanians what I'm saying is at the The
Gangs before you set off across the
channel if you're a migrant the
albanians are gangs brief them on how to
use loopholes in our law what I want to
do is to close those loopholes so if you
like I'm agreeing with the Albanian
prime minister we need to to fix our own
problem he needs to fix some too in
terms of traffic out of his country okay
you talk about um people not being able
to come here if you've come from a safe
country surely that means France Yeah
well yeah well it does I mean there's a
secondary issue here which which we
haven't addressed in this because it's
been going on for years and nobody seems
to be able to resolve it and that is
that any uh Asylum Seekers real primary
right is to be able to stop in the first
con first safe country they arrive in
right so that could be France in this
case if they've crossed Europe it's
about six other countries right but we
we can't enforce that but what we can do
is say you're an Albanian you go back to
Albania isn't that the problem though
that we can't enforce that isn't that
where the problems there are there are
several links in this problem what we're
what we're not addressing that one as
well because we're focusing on the one
that's quickest to fix I mean this one
if the if the government puts through
emergency legislation very very
unusually I mean I normally oppose a
much legislation but very very unusual
is a very very strong argument for doing
this be a very short bill it will go
through and basically we could say to
the Albanian population now anybody else
who comes across the channel will be
sent back and when that starts to happen
there's no bigger deterrent remember the
home office's argument on the Rwanda
policy for example is this is a
deterrent think there's no bigger
deterrent than if somebody in your
village pays thousands of pounds to a
human trafficker and then ends up back
in the village three weeks later yeah
um I'm glad you brought up Rwanda
because how's that working out for this
question well I'm not a fan of it I mean
I've got to be careful because I don't
uh not everybody who's signed a letter
agrees with me on that but I'm not a fan
of Rwanda policy because we've spent 140
million and the indications are that
even if it works at all it won't take
more than 200 people it's very it's it's
a bad idea it won't work yeah but my
point is that it's a piece of
legislation that was put through the
House of Commons by this government and
it has not been successful why do you
think emergency legislation which is
rushed through by you know it's very
description is going to be any more
effective because this addresses the two
main loopholes that are used by people
traffickers to bring people into Britain
illegally that's what it does the two
main loopholes one is in our uh in our
so I'm law one is in our trafficking law
and interestingly in November of 2021 I
think it was uh Sweden looked at this
and said
we're going to stop anybody claiming
Asylum from a safe country in this case
Albania and you know what they've
approved zero since a nobody's taken
them to court
um talk to me about
um the Tory Exodus while I've got you um
a lot of uh youngsters I'll describe
them as that Danny Davidson particularly
I mean she wasn't even born when you
became everybody's a youngster
at your child what's going on oh well I
think people uh some people are deciding
they don't they they've they came into
politics they enjoyed it for a while now
they don't you know I mean William Bragg
is he said it's he had a great time he's
been chairman of committee and so on
while he's still young enough to have
another career he's going to go and do
that you know that sort of thing that
sort of thing I can't tell you the
answers to all those I mean you know I'm
going to be here till I die in harness I
suspect um although am I right in saying
that your constituency is going to be
affected by boundaries again oh cutter
bits again you know yeah yeah third time
I mean I end up with about half of my
existing constituency
um but what's been the case since well I
mean
since over a decade
um is we've got in the eyes of the
boundary commission at least one too
many MPS for what was the old humbicide
that's East Yorkshire and Lincolnshire
and so they had to shrink them down and
uh so one will go and the boundary
change or the boundary commission
battery change commission
um do you think that they have the best
interests of the your constituents and
others in mind when they come up with
these new boundaries well I'm sure they
intend to
um whether they get it exactly right
well there's a consultation process we
are actually currently engaged in a
consultation process on that and uh
indeed we've I've talked to them I will
be writing them rather about one
component of my current constituency to
try and ensure that it stays together
rather than get broken up Center this
piece in that piece uh can I ask you
about wind farms where are you on that
um I'm not in favor of this so-called
Tory rebellion in favor of uh
liberalizing the law and wind farms
I've got one right next to I mean nearly
as close as the camera to my house
um the uh but but yeah it wasn't there
yes frankly but yeah it ruins the
skyline but so what the more important
Point here is that we've got offshore
wind farms now coming we've got to be
sure that when we go towards heading uh
hitting net zero that we do it in a way
that takes the population with us takes
the takes the the nation with us and
that that me that applies to whether
it's wind farms or massive solar Farms
now that we're covering half the half
the country with great tranches of the
country and uh in solar Farms fine let's
go down let's make it a least responsive
to the ideas of local people
um Before I Let You Go it would appear
that a way for conservative MPS to be
popular is to go on to I'm a celebrity
you think that's what Rishi cynics are
doing no certainly not no no I mean look
I I I've had to spend time in a jungle
eating horrible things but never on
television and and I wouldn't recommend
it it's good to see you thank you thank
you so much for taking the time to join
us this morning I really appreciate it
thank you